hello
my name is nicholas and i'm a member of
the wolf and alpha math content team
welcome to the wolfram tech conference
uh among the other dozen talks i'm sure
you're attending today
we'll be talking about new wolfram
language functionality that's been
incorporated in wolfram alpha in recent
times
so i'm not going to spend too much time
on the abstract
i'll pause here for a moment in case in
the future in the
version hosted on the web you can pause
and read the abstract if you'd like
i do want to highlight thanks to the
wolfram alpha math team of which i'm a
member
and the rest of the wolfmouth developers
of course
so wolfman alpha is perpetually in a
process of trying to keep pace with the
wolfram language itself
so wolf mouth is a large scale
development project written in the
wolfram language
it supports a broad ensemble of
functionality across many disciplines
from many facets of math elementary
mathematics algebra geometry calculus
linear algebra
differential equations ods and pdes
statistics etc all of the various
versions of applied math
for example science and technology
physics chemistry engineering
materials computational science and then
other aspects of life that
most normal humans care about uh society
and cultural facts
everyday life beta pertains those things
etc
all of this is rooted in
the wolfram language and the broader
wolfram technology stack
and wolfman alpha is at least of what i
know
one of the largest development projects
done in the wolfram language
and as those wolfram language roots grow
version by version
so too does the wolfram alpha web page
and
api accessibility
so wolfernoff has a natural language
pipeline
to the wolfram language itself so way
too with
common tongue communicate with the
computer and extract
data and calculations that you're
interested in without ever having to
code
right so
this serves you know the front-facing
immediate
thing everyone thinks of is the website
right
so for external users they log into the
website type in a query in natural
language they get
data or computations out of it
it also has accessibility to other
softwares via
web-based apis and partnerships with
major corporations such as apple where
we
incorporate things for siri especially
spoken results
amazon where you get spoken results with
alexa and microsoft
in which well from alpha functionality
calculations data
accessibility etc is being incorporated
in excel
for which i have various logos at the
bottom here so
basic function editions rendering
accessible
wolfram language functionality in
wolf alpha is critical to both the
development of the web page everyone
associates with wolf and alpha most
readily
and critical to the development of
content for web api accessibility and
partnerships in which software accesses
the wolfram
language viable from alpha
so we'll cover a broad range of
functionality additions we've made to
wolf and alpha based on progress in the
wolfram language
and this includes content that we've
been adding in particular from uh
version nine onwards as we're trying to
keep pace with wolfen language
developments
so a simple query you know some content
that you can imagine
you can conceive of a way of programming
in say
excel or god forbid c plus or c a low
level language
uh fairly easily
say you want to call a function that
will generate a vector
of a certain length and have that vector
be at a certain angle with respect to
the x-axis
right that's a couple trigonometric
functions in a few cells in excel
or a couple trigonometric functions in
some custom library that you're calling
from
c plus plus it's about 15 characters
if you just use apis or software with
accessibility to
wolf and alpha and so you can see here
if you can see my mouse
you can see we type in a natural
language query angled vector
of length 30 at an angle of pi over 4
with respect to the x-axis
it shows you its understanding of what
you stated and the corresponding result
this is fairly straightforward any
physics 1 physics 2 student
and you could implement this in a
broader array of softwares
but you can do this in probably most
easily by just natural language input in
wolfram alpha
a similarly simple example
on extracting the absolute value and
complex arguments in tandem
from say a list of quantities that
you're interested in
for example here 1 plus i 3 plus i 5
plus i
you could conceive of writing
functionality even for the complex
argument
in some other software it likely
wouldn't just be
10 to 20 characters right and
in the same instance you can see i'll
scroll down a little bit
you can see it understands your input it
takes the input calculates the absolute
value in the
in the argument of each of those
entities in the list of queries that you
wanted to make
and computes the immediate result
absolute value
argument for each of the quantities
additionally
and this would take additional code in
another software
you can ask for alternative forms so
other equivalent symbolic
representations of these
result quantities and convert them to
say logarithmic expressions or
other trigonometric expressions
so continuing this vein of just basic
function additions that make what would
be a fairly straightforward job in
another software
still significantly faster
we have something where say you want to
do a combination of string reversal
of an integer and you want to convert
that new number to a different base
and then only reserve uh return a
certain fraction of
those num uh the leading digits
so that's again about 10 to 20
characters in the wolfram language where
we've added functionality for the
function integer reverse from
the wolfram language to wolfram alpha
you can type in switch around the
integer
one two three four five so 12 345
do that and return the new result in
base 5 rather than base 10
and retain the leading 10 digits
and if you if you compute this it shows
you
what it interpreted as your natural
language input
and returns the result of 1858
125 and then gives you a couple other
representations
including things like the number length
number name etc
getting a little bit more difficult in
terms of implementation in another
software
would be uh the inquiry of
if a given number corresponds to a
mercen prime exponent
right so we want to know does 10 to the
10 correspond to a mersenne prime
exponent
now i'm not familiar enough with the
mathematics behind how you would write a
query like this
and so i can't conceive of exactly how
you would do this in excel or something
but it wouldn't surprise me if that's
feasible
however it's certainly feasible in
wolfram alpha right in 10 to 20
characters you
get the answer that no 10 to the 10 does
not correspond to a mercen prime
exponent
so all of that stuff in principle you
could conceive of writing in
another software fairly simply as you
get more
involved in higher level mathematics for
example
here rotational matrices it becomes more
and more
laborious to do those kind of things in
another language
but comparable difficulty to return
the computation in wolfram alpha so
you'll remember 10 to 20 characters
before got you the absolute value and
argument of a string of numbers
here the same number of characters about
10 to 15 will get you
a rotational matrix called an euler
matrix corresponding to rotations about
the x y and z
axis so i've just typed in some
reference values by which we want to
rotate
it produces the rotation matrix by which
you would multiply a vector
in order to get the rotated new vector
and that already is okay that would be a
trigonometric
headache in some other software
however it would be a linear algebra
headache as well to return the extra
pods that are returned here such as
characteristic polynomial the
eigenvalues eigenvectors
in particular the diagonalization of
that rotation matrix
so increasing degrees of complexity
in terms of the computation do not
necessarily entail increasing degrees of
complexity in
the natural language input that invokes
that computation
and this is a major selling point of
volt from alpha's website and the
ability to interface with other
softwares
it saves you development time for major
projects it saves you fun time
for i mean unless you're into
implementing
mathematics and code it saves you fun
time as you make natural language
queries just on the website
similarly for another kind of advanced
math topic elliptic functions so
a german guy named wire strauss invented
a few elliptic functions
and these have corresponding quantities
associated with the half periods three
half periods associated with these two
unique ones and one derived one
you can make queries on what is the
third half period
of a wire strauss elliptic function
corresponding to the first invariance
and the first and second invariance
rather with a given
numerical value and this will return
without you having to do any symbolic
calculations under the hood
a number in this case a purely imaginary
number
the position in the complex plane a data
visualization of that
and tell you the functions that it used
or some of the functions that it used in
the wolfram language in order to
compute these things so
this whole process of incorporating
wolfen language functionality
in wolfram alpha lends itself to direct
function calls
it also leads us lends itself to
in applied mathematics in particular the
calculation of
other quantities of interest based on a
given function that we think people
might be interested in for educational
purposes etc
for example we've had feature requests
in signal processing
where certain filters are used to
attenuate a signal
this attenuation for example in audio
technology
would be used to reduce white noise in
some low fidelity recording
such that your old-time recording of
some opera from the mid-1900s
sounds better on your modern technology
your modern
stereo and so audio engineers will use
these things called window functions
there's about 24 of them so far in the
wolfram language
all of which we're in the process of
adding support for in wolfram alpha
you can see here if we type in han
window one of the most basic window
functions
you get a plot back of the mathematical
window function itself
versus its variable x
and you get the resulting power spectrum
and this is in units of rel
frequency relative to the harmonic of
the input
sample input audio signal you get
the frequency attenuation that you would
expect if you apply this window function
as a filter to the audio signal and so
each of these have a different power
spectrum or extent to which they've
they attenuate different signals
relative to the original sample
and so each one is adept at reducing a
certain type of noise say one window
function might be
adept at eliminating pink noise one may
be adapted eliminating white noise etc
and this enhancement of wolfman alpha's
capacity to
return derivative quantities of interest
such as the power spectrum
from a query such as what is the han
window
as a function of x is one of the
redeeming qualities of
wolfmaff as an educational utility and
as an information utility for say
engineers in this case
so wolverine alpha we're focusing on in
this talk mathematics so the support for
pure mathematics in the first
portion of the talk support for a cool
instance of
applied mathematics in the latter
portion of the talk there
this support for mathematical
functionality is increasingly
comprehensive
the uh exhaustive scientific content and
mathematical content of the wolfram
language is paralleled in wolfram alpha
such that if you make a query in the
wolfram language
using this mathematical function data
symbol
you can return a host of functionality
about i think 400 functions three to 400
functions depending on your version of
wolfram language you're in
that are basic to advanced
mathematical functions this is a good
notion of
what functionality wolfram alpha should
support and the wolfram language
should support of these
there are about 150 in i think version
11
i used to generate this there are about
150 of these that are supported directly
in
the wolfram language this number is
increasing rapidly as versions proceed
i think it's already increased to some
from when i made this in
version 11 to version 12.1
all of these that the wolfram language
has in the mathematical function data
repository are supported in wool from
alpha now the 24 signal processing
functions and the few other highlights
that i've had here in the stocks
polished polished the mathematical data
function
support off from the amazing amount of
progress
the math content group and the other
developers with wolverine already had
so in this ever increasing wolfram
language
pipeline that is wolfram alpha we've
covered additions such as basic
mathematics computation with angles
their relation with vectors
computation with complex numbers
computation with
string rearrangement integer reversal
and base conversions
computation with advanced mathematics
elliptic functions rotational matrices
and applied mathematics in engineering
and signal processing
this is a small example of the progress
that the math content group and the
other
wolfen alpha developers have made in
recent times
for uh enhancing the support of the
wolfen language in
wolfram alpha i'm happy to address other
questions that you have on upcoming
functionality if you'd like to reach out
to me in my email
here and uh with any questions
immediately following the talk
thank you if anybody has any questions
i'm happy to take them
i will mention as you think of questions
if you have any
that i failed to highlight in that
histogram that i showed in about 14
minutes
the uh there respect to the function
rank
and which is the frequency of the
currents in the world from language
documentation which you can
get from wolfram alpha such that some
occur
you know they're the top 100 or 200
functions in terms of frequency of
occurrences
uh some are the top 200 most used
functions in both language some of them
are
you know the four thousandth most
frequently used function uh and we've
added support for these across the board
i think that's the only other clarifying
thing i mentioned that
i wanted to mention so if you have any
questions i'm happy to take them
nick we got one question right here from
michael
it's uh in the past chat yeah sure yeah
uh so for yeah i guess everybody can see
it on path of yes
for a notebook covering all of this and
uh yeah i can attach that
we i'll note that we're in the final
stages of adding most of this
these features and so the function calls
right now probably won't
return what you see in the notebook
itself
but i can attach i can attach that here
shortly after the session and uh
you can at least see what i showed in
the uh
the video itself and then at some point
those that functionality will just
return
with a nicer looking even set of pods
from the wolfram function in uh
mathematica or the wolfram language
so yeah i will upload that uh right
after the talk
yeah sweet and my manager highlighted
two to four weeks until most of the
stuff goes
uh on the production from alpha servers
we believe
so michael asked if the wolf from alpha
evaluator is different from the normal
mathematical and if somehow
uh so the function that i was using to
illustrate what the input strings that
would that will in the future prompt the
uh calculations that you were seeing
there uh is the wolfram alpha function
so i'm assuming that's what you're
referring to as the wolfram alpha
evaluator
and uh that will actually query wolfram
alpha and then return
piece by piece what pods that
it uh computes and so it can do that in
like
just by returning the pods directly so
uh
you can just request all the pods that's
just wolf alpha of and your inquiry
string
so say wolf and alpha of euler matrix
one two three
or you can request on a pod bipod basis
uh or you can
request the computable data version of
that where it strips away the pod
representation actually gives you say
the list that's the output for the
matrix
uh those are there is a syntactical way
to
request that when you're making the
function call to the wolfram alpha
function
in mathematica from the kernel and
there's also uh if you just make the
function call without any of the options
say wolf alpha of euler matrix of one
two three
and then in the when it returns all of
the pods at the top right of each pot i
believe
is a little dot dot option next
extension where you can say return the
computable data for this pod
or return the uh just this pod
specifically etc
and it will give you back how you could
have asked for that syntactically
and so i think it's easiest to uh use
that one from alpha function
to return all the pods and then access
the
piece by piece components from uh the
interactive interface
yeah the wolf and alpha function will
run in all mathematical kernel and then
return
the wolf alpha calculation associated
with your input string
i hope that's what you were asking about
with the wolf and alpha evaluator
right so uh michael pointed out that
there are well from alpha functions that
are not in mathematica potentially
and uh i think there there is
i'm not familiar with the rainbow
financial derivatives content
here specifically but there is content
that is
in wolfram alpha specifically that has
been developed from kernel functions but
aren't necessarily kernel functions
themselves
and uh that's likely the content that
you're talking about here with the
rainbow financial derivatives
there's other financial things like uh
you know amortization calculators and
stuff like that that uh
when when they were developed there
weren't kernel functions associated with
that content such that we did the you
know effective interest calculations etc
uh by hand or using what what kernel
functions did exist
and uh i think in that sense not only is
you know wolf and alpha trying to keep
up with
wolf language developments but the
wolverine language also
you know reflects developments that have
already been done in wolf and alpha to
some extent
uh we're in we'll write an amortization
calculator
not using kernel functions because they
don't exist yet and then kernel
functions will crop up
within the next five years after that
and uh so yeah there is some development
that uh
is done on the wolfram alpha side and
input strings will parse to those
functions uh
that are not necessarily supported in
the wolfram language with at least the
level of simplicity that i've
highlighted here so kyle you know i've
just reiterated that there's
many custom functions and wolfram alpha
that are not uh
not inherent in the wolfram language
from a direct symbol
but uh are built into alpha specifically
for
its development and uh that there's a
lot of use of
uh java language a-link as well
we'll also note that i've only been
working for overnight for about six
months so i'm sure that
kyle and other other members of our team
could answer this a lot better
jeremy did you still have a question
that's a good point that we should uh
you know they should the two software
should try to keep pace with each other
uh you can there's a so at the bottom of
like the
wolf and alpha page there's a feedback
form
and uh i mean that's designed for
wolfram alpha feedback specifically
but uh i'm sure if you put something in
there that
like a feature request say well from
alpha supports this would be great for
language could support this as well
that will make it into our bug system
and uh i'm sure it will be filed as a
feature request and so if there are
specific
uh financial functions that you that
you're seeking
i'm sure you could on that form or
another feedback form on the wolfram
website
uh request features okay
all right we got one more question from
michael i'm gonna go ahead and
unmute him and let him talk sure
yeah i was just saying it's it's it's
just not me it's also you know i've
constantly met people who are saying i
can get this amazing stuff from wolf
from alpha
but i have no way of doing it uh
actually in mathematica but it obviously
must be written in mathematica at some
level and it's on that
server um you know could that function
be made available
um i i don't see anything wrong with
that actually
i think that would help a lot because
for instance you know they're
we used to have a wonderful little thing
which they've now stopped where you
could
actually out ask for a portfolio
analysis just by listing tickers
and it would give up to four or five
tickers and then it would do a complete
portfolio analysis for you um
and but you know there was nothing
corresponding i could see parts and
you know i could generate copies of this
by doing some of my own coding
but still it was um it would be
interesting to have such a function
as must exist already in wolf from alpha
and rather than
reinventing the wheel all over again it
would be good to have those available in
mathematica
the way i got around it of course was to
call it call wolf from alpha
uh inside a mathematical function but um
that depending you know so that worked
fine
until i'd give a presentation and of
course you'd have
the two streams coming in a call to wolf
from alpha plus your zoom screen and
whatever and
as you know they don't work wonderfully
um and so you
the whole thing would freeze um so it
would be good
if these functions could be you know
transferred over
um i mean they're there i can't see what
great difficulty there must be unless
you know they're so enmeshed in other
functions that go down
so many levels that it's just too much
of a nightmare to ever undo the lot but
it would be something i think which
should um not only increase the
functionality in mathematica but
allow for a greater correspondence
between the two functions which has been
an ongoing
um thing
over the you know really for the past
decade so
and kyle and jeremy have made mention in
the chat here the
in instances where things are not too
nested such that there is a
dedicated function that we can't extract
we've uh
made effort to take those internal those
wolfram
internal functions and turn them into uh
wolfram function repository editions
so stuff that is not necessarily a
kernel function because of the long
development times of that
the stuff that is accessible from the
kernel by calling a resource function
yeah and uh so we we have been putting
an effort to uh
convert what is the functions that are
not too nested
in uh in many layers like you're saying
to function repository editions
in terms of stuff that relies on data
like financial information for example
portfolios and stuff
i think at some point uh sometimes if
you say if you run polyhedron data or
chemical data
you'll have a small wait time because
it's downloading something from the
server
so i'm not sure if we can get around
that yeah
that kind of functionality but yeah i'm
very supportive now the community
development aspects of
making things a little bit more open and
stuff on uh and the functional
repository serves that purpose well and
we're trying to move in that direction
yeah i have looked at that but often you
find that there's some function
and it's wrapped in compute
[Music]
which does nothing in mathematica but
it's obviously calling
uh an evaluator in wolfe from alpha so
i'd have to download all of
the wolfram alpha uh application in
order for it to work
[Music]
yeah yeah in instances if you find a
function that you think
seems like conceptually would it would
be uh
easy to separate from you know the other
the other development
uh developmental code like feel free to
send us a
bug report and stuff like that we'll try
to we'll try to make those
okay all right that would
that would be great thank you very much
thank you
no problem thank you
okay all right i think we still have
nine minutes because my talk ran a
little bit short so if anybody else has
questions feel free
i think it will automatically boot us up
uh
yeah jeremy highlighted specifically uh
there's a
with a link that he provided in the chat
there uh
where you can pin down what stuff has
been added by internal users such as
our group the wolf alpha math content
team
uh you can look at the function
repository editions that our
group has done specifically such that uh
you don't have to dig through all of the
wolfram function repository editions to
find the stuff that
we thought was best transferred from the
wolframatic internal
code to uh kernel accessible functions
so uh that subset of the wfr might be
interesting to you
stuff will these functions as they're
listed in the notebook will compute
in the next two to four weeks likely and
so if you run them right now it may
return uh no information and that uh
these are
very current developments but uh yeah we
can upload you know upload the notebook
and
if nobody else has any questions we'll
wrap up and go ahead and do that
well thank you everybody
you